[Music]
it's time for et's social study your
quick look at what the Stars are posting
online Dancing with the Stars paid
tribute to the late great foreign tender
sin' this week on TV and Tuesday judge
Carrie Ann Inaba shared this sweet snap
spending time with the star the show
placed on the ballroom floor in honor of
the actress meanwhile Ava Philip you
wish to mom Reese Witherspoon a happy
birthday with this pic calling her mom
the best friend then there's Kim
Kardashian with this throwback shot she
captioned squad I feel like we are so
blessed to have the best support system
in the best family
oscar-winner Maher saleh ali also posted
a family pic hanging out with his
newborn daughter and coco austin is
snapchatted with baby chanel revealing
that she's still breastfeeding she's 15
and check out Megan Fox the mama free
looking at sexier than ever in this
sneak peek at her new campaign for a
lingerie company Frederick's of
Hollywood Teresa Giudice also showing
off her fit figure she captioned it this
big loving the Sun hashtag it's yoga
like yoga is totally change my life
[Music]